we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail question that is an
interesting one and we haven't really
addressed this much so let's take a
listen hey david a skeptical human here
um i wanted to get your take on the idea
of the means testing of social benefits
whether we're talking about social
security free college medicare for all
and by means testing of course i mean
this idea that wealthy people since they
can afford things like college for
themselves or healthcare for themselves
it should have be provided to them
through the tax they're from this pool
of money thanks and keep up the good
work like so i understand the instinct
here right which is if you're a
billionaire do you need seventeen
hundred bucks a month and Social
Security benefits for example not really
it makes no difference to you so I
understand saying what if we start means
testing some of these programs where if
your wealth or income exceeds some
threshold you don't get it
I don't think this is a good idea okay
first of all if you've contributed it's
not super clear to me how you say that
you're not eligible that that's number
one I don't understand how you can
really do that but what's more important
to me as an argument against me means
testing these types of programs is that
the bureaucracy needed to do the means
testing means that you have a means
testing apparatus which costs money and
this is part of what drives up the cost
of many of the programs that we want to
try to reduce the cost of so healthcare
is a great example a lot of what makes
it so that the health care system we
have costs what it does to run and costs
what it does for the end users the
consumers of health care services is
this massive apparatus that exists
around for many of the state-funded
public option type programs you have to
means test those for the hospitals the
medical billing apparatus bureaucracy
costs money what we're trying to do is
limit that in order to reduce cost the
other reason I wouldn't
start doing means-testing for these
programs is that you create stigma
around claiming of the benefits okay if
you have too much money and you don't
qualify it starts to imply that by
receiving a social benefit you're sort
of branding yourself in a particular way
which people may not really want to do
for better or worse that could be
something we say it shouldn't be that
way but it is there is stigma around
some of these programs so what you end
up doing really is increasing the cost
of the programs and diverting money away
from the money that could actually go to
people by having these means testing
apparatus and when you means test it's
known to hurt those in the middle
because when there's a cut-off point
people on the sort of borderline will
start to make financial decisions in
order not to start losing benefits by
going above what those limits are it
creates this gaming mentality the stigma
component so I'm against it I understand
morally the reason why many people would
look at that I don't think it's a good
idea I don't think it's something that
the left should run on if you disagree
let me know we've got a great bonus show
for you today three great stories and
more david pakman.com slash membership
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
get instant access to the bonus show